[Music]
this video is my visual interpretation
of Raymond ibrahim's book Defenders of
the West if you're looking to understand
the Crusades through just one book this
is it I highly recommend purchasing a
copy for yourself the first chapter of
the book explores the reasons behind the
Crusades and introduces Godfrey as a
central leader due to its length I've
divided the 3D animation visualization
of the first chapter into several
videos beginning in the 4th Century as
the Roman Empire started to christianize
Jerusalem where Christ was crucified
buried and resurrected gained
significant importance and emerged as
the focal point of
pilgrimage in the 330s Constantine the
Great
commanded construct a grand Temple
complex on the side of Christ's burial
uncover the True Cross made from
fragments of the execution instrument
and enshrine it within the
temple yes
s then the grand Temple was built under
the emperor's order and it became known
as the holy
Seiler the temple became known as the
holy Seiler both the temple and the
cross would hold immense significance
for Christendom and profoundly influence
the trajectory of this video
series Constantine died in the year of
337 precisely 300 years after
Constantine's death the Arabs who had
recently unified under the banner of
Islam conquered Jerusalem from the
Eastern Roman Empire in 637 thereafter
the Christians of the Holy Land were
generation after generation persecuted
to the point of Slaughter and
destruction suffered at the hands of
Muslim
rulers for example in the early 8th
Century 70 Christian pilgrims in
Jerusalem were tortured and executed for
refusing to convert to
Islam seven who converted were
spared some years after that another 60
pilgrims were crucified in
Jerusalem in the late 8th Century
Muslims destroyed two churches and a
monastery near
Bethlehem they also slaughtered its
monks in 796 Muslims burned another 20
monks to
death in 809 and again in 813 multiple
monasteries convents and churches were
attacked in and around Jerusalem
Christians of both sexes were gang and
massacred on Palm Sunday of 929 another
wave of atrocities broke out churches
were destroyed and Christians
slaughtered not every Muslim leader was
committed to the destruction of churches
and persecution of Christians some were
more pragmatic leaving dius alone on
payment of gesia and acceptance of
social inferiority that said and as in
other Muslim occupied territories
whether the next ruler would be radical
or moderate to use an anachronistic but
familiar dichotomy was always a coin
flip away as for the Muslim populace
then as now mobs were always ready to
Rise Against and plunder Christians
under any
pretext even the holy Seer Christendom
most sacred church was not spared in 936
the Muslims in Jerusalem made a rising
and burnt down the church which they
plundered and destroyed all they could
of it records one Muslim
chronicler similarly in 1009 Fatimid
khif hakeim B Allah ordered one of his
officials destroy the Seiler church and
have the people plunder it so thoroughly
all traces of it were
obliterated they did exactly
that such wanten vandalism plunged the
entire church and the city of Rome into
deep grief in distress to quote the pope
of the time sergius the
Ford not content hakeim further ordered
the destruction of according to Muslim
accounts some 30,000 churches throughout
Egypt and greater
Syria although a much smaller church was
rebuilt over the Seiler of Christ in
1048 this church also remained under
threat subsequent Muslim rulers
permitted Christians to rebuild the
church due to the significant revenues
generated by Christian pilgrimages
despite the risk of another Infidel
Church being
destroyed as William of Ty an important
Crusades chronicler born and raised in
the Holy Land writes when the Muslims
desired to exact anything by force from
either the patriarch or the people any
delay in rendering obedience was
immediately followed by the threat that
the church would be pulled
down around the same time the SE was
being rebuilt the seljuk Turks Rose to
power in Afghanistan and Eastern Iran in
the 1040s occupied Baghdad in 1055
keeping the Abbasid cffs as figureheads
and continued marching Westward into
Syria no other Muslim peoples would come
to spearhead the Jihad as the Turks had
both friend and foe attest to their
martial prowess and religious Zeal as
Bernard Lewis writes the converted Turks
sank their national identity in Islam as
the Arabs and Persians had never done
accordingly under Turkish influence
Islam regained the Zeal of the early
Arab conquests and reopened holy war
against its Christian foes on a
significant scale matters went from bad
to worse for the people of the ancient
Christian region of Asia Minor the
future turkey particularly those on its
easternmost Edge where the Turks first
began to invade namely the Armenians
hundreds of thousands of these
Christians were either massacred or
enslaved and thousands of churches were
torched or transformed into
mosques the pivotal moment came in 1071
after the decisive Turkish victory over
the Eastern Roman Empire at manzikert
which opened the rest of the Anatolian
plane to turkic
Islam then the sjuk sultan Muhammad bin
daud chagi or Alp arsan called on his
followers run through the countryside
day and night slay the Christians and do
not spare any Mercy on
them eagerly they obliged and penetrated
Westward as a result cities were
obliterated lands were plundered and the
whole of Romo or Anatolia was stained
with Christian blood writes the Eastern
Roman Princess Anna comini all that was
left were devastated Fields trees cut
down mutilated corpses and towns driven
mad by fear or
inflames the Byzantine emperor alexios
the fur comenos who reigned from 1081 to
1118 recounted his people's
travails how hard the most holy Roman
Christian Empire is being pressed by the
Turks pillaged daily and constantly
raided with Christians being murdered
and mocked in various Indescribable
ways not only did the Muslim Invaders
defile the holy places in innumerable
ways and Destroy them but they would
circumcise Christian boys and youths
above Christian baptismal fonts pour the
blood from the circumcision into the
fonts in mockery of Christ force them to
urinate on it and then drag them around
the church and force them to blaspheme
the name and Faith of the Holy Trinity
those who refuse are subjected to
various punishments and eventually
killed
as for Christian women the Muslim
Invaders took virgins and made them
public
prostitutes mothers were violated in the
presence of their daughters over and
over again by different men while their
daughters were compelled not only to
watch but to sing obscene songs and to
dance then they changed places and the
suffering which is painful and shameful
to speak of was inflicted upon the
daughters while the filthy activity was
adorned by the obscene songs of the
unfortunate
mothers when the female sex was not
spared they became worse than animals
breaking all human laws by turning on
men their lust overflowed to the point
that the execrable and profoundly
intolerable crime of sodomy which they
committed against men of middle or low
station
[Applause]
they also committed against a certain
Bishop killing him a medieval pelet and
chronicler named William of Ty lamented
that conditions scarcely better in the
Holy
Land Jerusalem's Christians endured even
greater hardships under the Turks making
their past tribulations under the
Egyptian fmds and the Persian abbasids
seemed comparatively lighter in
retrospect death threatened them every
day and what was worse than death the
fear of servitude harsh and intolerable
ever lowered before them William
proceeds to offer a typical
example even as the Christians
celebrated their holy rights the Turkish
enemy would violently force their way
into the churches which had been
painstakingly restored and preserved
after earlier destruction under the
Egyptians and
Persians utterly without reverence for
the consecrated places they sat upon the
very altars and struck Terror to the
heart of the worshippers with their mad
cries and
whistling they overturned the chales
trod underfoot the utensils devoted to
the Divine offices broke the marble
statues and showered blows and insults
upon the
clergy the Lord patriarch then in office
was dragged from his seat by hair and
beard and thrown to the
ground again and again he was seized and
thrust into prison without cause
treatment fit only for the lowest slave
was inflicted upon him in order to
torture his people who suffered with him
as with a
father nor were European pilgrims to
Jerusalem spared as the Turks were
ruling the lands of Syria and Palestine
they inflicted injuries on Christians
who went to prey in Jerusalem beat them
pillaged them and levied the pole tax or
gizia moreover every time they saw a
caravan of Christians particularly of
those from Rome and the land of Italy
they made every effort to cause their
death in diverse
ways it was in this abysmal context that
at the Council of Claremont on November
27th
1095 Pope Urban II called for what came
to be known as the First
Crusade after describing to the
assembled Lords and Nobles the plight of
Eastern Christendom under Islam he cried
who is to repair this damage if you do
not do it rise up and remember the manly
Deeds of your ancestors including the
prowess and greatness of
Charlamagne for the Marshall Knights of
the West hearing of the aforementioned
Muslim atrocities against Christendom
was
intolerable thus when Urban concluded by
calling on them to undertake an armed
pilgrimage to Jerusalem with the twin
goals of Defending fellow Christians and
liberating the Seiler of
Christ with one voice all in assembly
cried out God wills
it thereafter and in the words of the
Contemporary Armenian chronicler Matthew
of adessa who lived Circa 1075 to
1144 all the peoples of Italy and Spain
right up to the confines of Africa and
even the distant Frankish Nation began
to move and surged forth in a formidable
and immense throng they were very much
like the Sands of the Seas which are
beyond the mind's
calculation the noblemen of the Frankish
Nation rose up and came forth each of
them came with his troops to Aid the
Christians to deliver the holy city of
Jerusalem from the infidels and to free
the holy Seiler from the hands of the
Muslims they were illustrious men of
Royal Blood endowed with piety and faith
faith and brought up in the practice of
good
works here are the names of these
Franks first to be named in Matthew's
list is Godfrey a Mighty Man from the
lineage of the Roman
emperors if you're enjoying what you've
seen so far please consider supporting
the author Raymond Ibrahim by purchasing
his book Defenders of the West stay
tuned for the next episode